[Musique]
on sera tous ses points de vue merci
d'être fidèle un autre rendez vous
quotidien dans le plaisir ce soir
d'accueillir nicolas baverez bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes et céistes avocat
éditorialiste au figaro on va revenir
d'ailleurs sur votre chronique de ce
matin dans le figaro votre dernier livre
l'alertent démocratique a été publié aux
édition de l'observatoire et puis nous
attendons d'une seconde à l'autre
alexandre ii vecchio qui comme vous le
savez est le responsable des pages
débats du figaro magazine qui est aussi
en charge du figaro vox nous allons
commencer par parler de ce passeport
sanitaires c'est thierry breton qui il a
présenté hier au grand jury rtl lci le
figaro alors ce passeport nous a
expliqué le commissaire européen
il va être donné à tous ceux qui se sont
vaccinés écouter thierry breton
nous avons pensé qu'il était très
important qu'à partir du moment où nous
pourrions être sûr que chaque européen
oui qui souhaitent se faire vacciner
aura un accès équitable au vaccin et ça
ça va arriver dans les deux trois mois
qui viennent sans discrimination à ce
moment là effectivement il sera bon que
l'on puisse avoir
je dirais un mécanisme je dirais une
certain remplaça donc un certificat qui
démontre votre état voilà donc un
certificat pour les gens qui se sont
fait vacciner mais pas seulement se
passe s'il s'appelle sanitaires et par
axe inhalent et clément bonne le
secrétaire d'état en charge des
questions européennes à expliquer
pourquoi ce matin à nos confrères de sud
radio
le mont solitaire est très important et
pas vaccinale au sens où vous n'aurez
pas d'abord évidemment d'obligations et
de vacciner et vous n'aurez même pas de
l'obligation de présenter une preuve de
vaccins on pourra montrer sur ces
petites applications européenne seoul ap
on pourra montrer que ce soit qu'on les
vacciner soi qu'on a fait un test
négatif soit qu'on a déjà ulcos vides et
qu on est immunisé et se tapent lication
sur un commune au niveau européen poupe
mais en revanche est normal aujourd'hui
il ya déjà des restrictions qu'on a sous
pli c'est un peu en disant vous pourrez
circuler en europe soit si vous avez un
test pcr négatif soit si vous êtes
vacciné et se passe sanitaires voilà à
quoi pourra ressembler un tel qu'il a
été présenté hier par thierry breton
on espère juste que d'ici à ce qu'on
nous le distribuons puisse le traduire
en français nicolas baverez c'est une
bonne initiative
c'est une très bonne initiative qui est
indispensable elle est indispensable
d'abord pour des raisons simplement
sanitaire c'est que au fur et à mesure
que se développent les tests et les
vaccins on a dit risque de contrefaçon
et donc le fait d'avoir ça va d'abord
permettre d'homologuer des filières et
d'être certain que les gens ont été
testés ou vacciner selon les bonnes
procédures
ensuite on voit bien que la situation
est en train de devenir insupportable
pas seulement sur le plan économique
avec les secteurs fermés avec les
frontières fermées mais aussi sur le
plan humain psychologiques sociales donc
il faut ré ouvrir mais pour réouvrir on
ne pu réouvrir que dans des conditions
sanitaires sur et c'est pour ça que ce
passeport est indispensable et j'ajoute
que c'est vrai que depuis le début de
cette épidémie un des points sur
lesquels l'europe avait été défaillante
c'est vraiment une de ses missions
c'est précisément la libre circulation
des personnes
quand on avait vu cette espèce
d'émiettement complet avec des états qui
étaient complètement non coordonnés avec
du coup l'épidémie qui circulait parce
que dès qu'on est à rouvray un peu les
gens se précipitaient pour pouvoir
bénéficier des musées des restaurants et
d'une vie normale ou en italie
verse et si on veut par ailleurs ouvrir
donc les secteurs décisifs du transport
aérien du tourisme il faut le faire
dernière chose qui est très importante
c'est que la reprise va être forte mais
elle va être hétérogènes et les premiers
qui vont repartir en bénéficieront
davantage le transport aérien est un
très très bon signal un indicateur
annoncé qu est-ce qu on constate
aujourd'hui en chine
il est de retour à 90 % de sa capacité
aux états unis 50% en europe 10 % donc
si on continue comme ça le retard des
vaccins le retard des diversement du
plan de relance
si en plus qu'on n'arrive pas à réouvrir
nos frontières
l'europe va vraiment être le dindon de
la farce donc il faut accélérer sur les
vaccins mais il faut aussi mettre en
place très vite
ce passeport qui doit être un passeport
numérique et comment à tous les
européens
voilà ajoutant que ce type de documents
existent déjà dans des pays comme israël
où vous devez donc fournir votre
application avec le qr code que vous
scannez pour avoir accès par exemple à
des restaurants ou à des spectacles
culturels
que répondez-vous nicolas baverez à ceux
qui disent que avec un tel passeport un
degré supplémentaire serait franchie
dans le dans le flicage des gens on sera
à tout moment qui est vacciné qui ne
l'est pas je crois que c'est exactement
l'inversé parce que vous ayez depuis le
début le problème c'est l'analyse des
risques et la proportionnalité
donc qu'est ce qui est le mieux c'est de
confiner tout le monde
ce qu'on va finir par faire de nour avec
des attestations dans tous les sens où
le fait de pouvoir ré ouvrir et avoir un
système de retour à la vie normale avec
ce passeport sanitaire par ailleurs ce
passeport
il fonctionne sur un principe de
responsabilité c'est qu'il faut jamais
oublier que en se faisant tester surtout
en se faisant vacciner on se protège
mais on protège les autres donc que par
ailleurs les personnes qui aient un
comportement responsable puisse
bénéficier
de l'accès à un certain nombre de
services ou d'activités c'est
parfaitement normal la condition qui a
été rappelé en revanche c'est
qu'évidemment il faut que le vaccin soit
accessible à tous ceux qu'il a tout ce
qu'il souhaite et c'est là dessus que
l'europe doit absolument rattraper le
retard qu'elle a qu'elle a accumulées et
qui est en retard
c'est un peu la même chose que pour la
france si vous voulez ça montre que
depuis le début il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas de vraie analyse des risques ou de
compréhension
on va revenir à la gestion globale par
l'europe de de la pandémie depuis le
début de cette crise nos internautes
sont moins affirmatifs que vous en tout
cas moins enthousiaste considère que ce
passeport sanitaire n'est pas à la
hauteur alors peut-être que ça veut dire
qu'on n'en fait pas assez c'est plus une
question d'interprétation en tout cas
65% des internautes qui s'expriment sur
twitter pour donner leur avis pense cela
dominique gombert sur lefigaro.fr nous
dit petit à petit sous couvert de bonnes
raisons médicales on nous impose un
traçage numérique un jour il n'y aurait
plus le choix
le sucre ajouter quelque chose c'est que
le traçage numérique en l'occurrence
c'est assez absurde parce que nous tous
on a déjà des carnets de vaccination je
vous le rappelle que si on va à la
mairie on ne brandit pas son oxydation
musique que ce soit numérique ou sait
mais si vous voulez voyager dans un
certain nombre de pays vous devez être
vaccinés contre la fièvre jaune et vous
ne rentrez pas si vous ne présentez pas
alors c'est un document papier
le fait qu'ils soient numérisés très
franchement c'est ce que j'ai c'est
plutôt quelque chose qui va réduire les
fraudes donc là dessus je je je pense
qu'ils voulaient on a été en retard sur
les masques sur les tests sur les mecs
sur les ventilateurs
si on peut éviter d'être en retard sur
le passeport de ce serait quand même
bien alexandre vecchio vos quêtes agents
spécialistes d'aurel
est ce que vous voyez dans ce passeport
une menace pour les libertés
démocratiques aération et nicolas
baverez à terme 2
de bureaucratie de contrôle on est
rarement en retard en france celle qui
peut paraître un peu paradoxal c'est que
je trouve que ce débat via bientôt alors
que on est très très mal joueurs et à ne
pas être vaccinés donc mais sur quelle
ainsi parce que vous n'êtes pas ou est
ce que vous êtes contre ce genre de deux
passes sur le principe je préfère éviter
ensuite c'est une question de d'urgence
sanitaire ou pas de réticence ou pas de
la population à se faire vacciner
je crois pas tellement aux héros coville
je pense que de toute manière l'épidémie
va reprendre aussi l'année prochaine
avec il faudra refaire des campagnes de
vaccination donc on sera jamais les
radis cra pas totalement donc je pose
que la chose vivre en partie avec malgré
tout et donc voilà je suis prudent si je
peux servir dans la suite au le lever
sport sanitaire parce que précisément
comme on va devoir vivre longtemps avec
les variants les pandémies et c'est le
fait d'avoir un dispositif qui permet de
c'est quand même la seule une des
manières de vivre avec ces virus et de
retourner à une vie normale tout en
ayant des conditions sanitaires
acceptables
ce que je crois c'est qu'il nous sera
imposé pour être tout à fait honnête ne
serait ce que pour voyager ce qui existe
déjà pour le fait de voyager je veux
dire que ça me choque pas pour le fait
d'aller au restaurant au cinéma etc
je suis on a déjà des badges dans tous
les sens chez moi j'avais j'en ai déjà
un peu assez de ces badges tendance à
les oublier les perdre et qu'il faut
sortir show cuir code à chaque fois et
puis c'est vrai qu'on se dit qu'elle
qu'elle va être l'étape supplémentaire
est ce convoi nous le le greffé
directement dans la pop âgée j'exagère
non voilà c'est pour ça que je ne vais
pas parce que l'art est ce qu'on va dire
que je suis complotistes est que je
nourris les théories du complot mais si
on va jusqu'au bout de la logique
pourquoi pas doit quelques années c'est
pas une évolution que j'appelle
de mes voeux il faut voir encore une
fois quel est le nom contexte sanitaire
les prochains mois et dans les
prochaines années
deux réactions celle de rose d'or sur
youtube qui le dit et le secret médical
si tout se tous les gens qui ont des
comorbidités sont vaccinés quel est
l'intérêt d'un passeport sanitaires et
puis futur origines toujours sur youtube
au pij et des gens à se faire vacciner
créer un nouveau social estimées qui a
le droit et qui n'a pas le droit d'avoir
accès à certaines choses c'est immoral
extrémiste et inhumain navale au moins
un point de vue tranché nicolas baverez
est ce que votre enthousiasme pour le
pass sanitaire irait jusqu'à le
préconiser à l'intérieur de l'entreprise
ou est-ce que le secret médical
notamment vis-à-vis de l'employeur fait
qu'on devrait ça là pour le coup on peut
identifier les gens mais que ça n'a pas
lieu d'être
enfin il faut pas tout confondre c'est à
dire que évidemment le secret médical
fait partie de dés des choses qui
doivent être protégés et le fait je le
répète aujourd'hui vous avez un système
de secret médical vous avez tous chaque
citoyen français un carnet de
vaccination donc le fait d'avoir se
passe sur le vaccin
kovy d'où les tests n'implique en ao de
quelques manières que ce soit n'implique
nullement qu'on lève le secret munich et
qu'on doive se passe vous n'aurez pas
les comorbidités oui mais oui mais par
exemple est-ce que vous est ce que avoir
se passe par exemple pour entrer dans
son entreprise
sinon on est obligé de faire du
télétravail est ce que ça vous paraît
excessif comme tories caution ensuite il
faudra regarder ce que ce que souhaite
mettre en place les entreprises
il me semble que il ya certaines
entreprises qui devront sans doute y
avoir recours je prends un exemple
l'hôtellerie de luxe si on veut avoir
des clients
de très haut de gamme ses clients eux
mêmes ce voyage et seront sans doute
vacciner ils seront mais où les hôtesses
tout le personnel navigant commercial
voilà exactement le transport aérien je
pense que tout un certain nombre de
secteurs comme ça seront demandés bon il
va falloir le dis je ne pense pas du
tout que évidemment que ce soit une
règle générale sera payée et là où il
faut revenir à la raison c'est qu'on va
pas demander un pass sanitaires pour
aller acheter une baguette ou aller au
supermarché
en revanche c'est vrai que le retour de
certaines et dans certaines professions
ce sera peut-être indispensable il ya
des professions par laquelle pourrait à
mon avis c'est complètement
indispensable c'est les professions de
santé c'est quand même la base
aujourd'hui le coc vide c'est la
première des maladies nosocomiales qu'on
attrape donc quand on va à l'hôpital
donc si on prend déjà l'hôpital
eh bien je pense que s'il ya des
secteurs où effectivement ce secteur-là
était évidemment le bon sens le commande
peut-être qu'il faudra dans des secteurs
qui sont de service public en contact
avec la population je pense l'éducation
nationale la police il ya des secteurs
sans doute aussi de service public où il
faudra que ce soit est effectivement
demandé en tout cas pour les pour les
postes qui sont en contact avec le
public
il faudra être quand même encadrée ça
très bien parce que toi il dans
l'hypothèse où pour aller au théâtre au
cinéma ou au restaurant il faudrait
sortir ce passeports numérisés faut pas
non plus que ce soit un outil pour
justement faire de tracking savoir
exactement où on est on fait comme
activité fin il n'y a pas de choses
après coup c'est vrai que ça nécessite
un débat je pense nourris et effet faire
entrer là dedans avec eux avec peu
denses ensuite moi je vois que sur le on
n'est pas face à une épidémie d'ebola
non plus tiens du moment où il y aura
façon de 70% de la population vaccinée
est ce que il faut voir enfin ça
nécessite de mettre en place toutes ces
techniques cet ingénieur et je ne suis
pas sûr non plus alors j'entends qu'il
peut y avoir d'autres épidémies
le grave mais il sera toujours temps de
moi je fais confiance pour le coup à
l'administration à la bureaucratie
française pour mettre en place très vite
ce type de système alors que le retard
là dessus j'ai bien prendre peur sur le
choix qui ont été bons à l'élite à
l'agrégation c'est qu'est-ce qui vaut
mieux c'est à voir
les hôtels les restaurants la culture
l'événement si elle tous fermés ou
d'avoir un pass sanitaires à mon avis il
vaut mieux un pass annie terre pour des
raisons pas seulement économique il ya
là soyons clairs ce terme n'est pas ce
qui a prévalu s'est en revanche pas ce
qu'il y'a pas la deuxième jour les
hôpitaux etc et parader en clair ces
matériaux font un passeport si on pousse
la logique franc brestois vaccinale pour
la ville c'est en quelques années que le
si tout va bien ce sera comme une grippe
et à la mer alors donc on peut
multiplier à la verse et cela met le
public et les passer encore
contrairement à la chine
en aucun cas il faut que ce passeport
sanitaire puis s'être croisées avec
d'autres données personnelles a fortiori
les données médicales ou des données de
déplacement ça alors vous parliez de la
bureaucratie française alexandre ii
vecchio la chronique de nicolas baverez
ce matin dans le figaro est
particulièrement sévère sur la gestion
de la crise sanitaire par l'état
français
vous nous dites nicholas ou la perte de
contrôle de la situation sanitaire
pointe la défaillance d'un état obèse et
un puissant dont la bureaucratie
foisonnante a fait la démonstration de
son incapacité à gérer les crises
un an après le début de la pandémie
l'échec est total
actée par le basculement des pouvoirs
publics dans le chaos
est ce que vous y allez pas un peu fort
quand même parce que c'est vrai que
on patauge emmanuel macron a du mal mais
c'est pas beaucoup mieux dans les autres
pays d'auch quand même d'abord en termes
de nombre de victimes ou en termes de
récession d'augmentation du des dettes
on est quand même parmi les pays les
plus touchés
et puis surtout ce qui est très frappant
c'est que il ya eu aucun progrès depuis
un an c'est à dire que les états unis ou
le royaume uni ont fait bien pire
pendant les premières vagues mais se
sont rattrapés si je puis dire sur la
vaccination ce qui est quand même très
préoccupant c'est que un an après le
début ce qui a relevé la cour des
comptes c'est la cour des comptes qu'il
dit y'a pas un lit de réanimation plus
il y en a plus de quelques dents en
moins
donc les médecins feront comme la
première fois ils vont tripler en
bricolant la capacité de réanimation en
faisant des délits de effectivement de
soins critiques qui est de la
réanimation un peu un peu dégradée on se
retrouve avec donc des capacités saturé
on se retrouve en réalité avec un
confinement qui ne dit pas son nom
et là où je parle de chaos c'est que
quand même accélérer la vaccination sans
vaccin accélérer la vaccination tout en
suspendant à des vaccins pendant 48
heures ce qui a aucun sens ça laisse
quand même peu pantois président de la
république qui contredit son premier
ministre à 24 heures de d'intervalle ça
contribue quand même pas à donner une
image de d'une très grande visibilité et
on voit aujourd'hui que en réalité il ya
aucun cap donc cette semaine va encore
se passer avec la chronique des
autorités médicales des autorités
politiques des élus locaux sur est-ce
qu'on recompte finesse qu'on ne confine
pas tout le monde attend l'oracle qui a
tombé jeudi
comme d'habitude très franchement c'est
pas une manière de
de gérer un pays donc la vérité c'est
qu'il ya plus de cap et que l'état est
complètement est complètement est
complètement balayées voilà c'est dit
leçons du fiasco français et européen
c'est à retrouver sur le figaro.fr
oui un mot de coup de rabot sur le
défendent emmanuel marc non je vais pas
défendre
emmanuel macron mais je pense que sur
l'état ou obèses et impuissants qui est
un peu là la formule consacrée
chez les libéraux s'est pas entièrement
faux mais il faut savoir ce qu'on met
derrière l'état je pense que s'il me dit
que l'état tchèque technocratique
bureaucratique et aux belges suis
d'accord avec vous l'état régalien les
plats stratège il me paraît
effectivement un puissant mais pas obèse
voir qu'à peu près tout depuis le début
de cette crise donc dans la refondation
de l'état qui à mon avis va être le
sujet de un des sujets des prochaines
années il faut pas se tromper et
refonder comme on a essayé de le faire
en supprimant en rognant sur l'état
régalien presse est vraiment je dirais
absolutisme un puissant plus que état
obèse et un puissant parce qu'il ya ce
se souvenir de la monarchie absolue ce
souvenir de l'état gaulliste très
performant très fort donc un état qui
effectivement veut se mêler de tout et
qui est d'une très grande puissance même
à faire respecter les propres règles
tatillonnes qui leur impose tout lé bien
voilà c'est dit de l'année réaction pour
finir sur ce passeport sanitaire celle
de nicole 0,6 sur lefigaro.fr à
passeport sanitaire quand trop peu de
gens sont vaccinés c'est injuste et à
dld qui renchérit un passeport solitaire
est juste si tous les français majeurs
et volontaires sont vaccinés ce qui
devrait être effectif au troisième
trimestre croisons les doigts
vous connaissez sûrement
ce bateau il s'appelle ever given c'est
le
porte conteneurs le plus célèbre du
monde
il fait 400 mètres de long et il a eu la
mauvaise idée il ya six jours maintenant
de se coincer en travers du canal de
suez alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que
les efforts importants déployés par
l'administration du canal pour
désensabler spa leurs bateaux sont en
train de porter leurs fruits il devrait
être
il est en train d'être dégagés et que le
trafic va reprendre mais ce qui s'est
passé est assez impressionnant puisque
vous savez qu'il ya cinquante navires
par jour qui traversent ce canal ça
représente 13 % du trafic mondial de
matières premières et de et de bien vous
voyez sur cette photo sur ces images
plutôt qui sont prises d'avion c'est
dizaine de bateaux qui attendait il y en
a eu jusqu'à 200 à l'exemple de vecchio
est ce que c'est juste une espèce de
petit petit accident ce qui se passe là
où c'est le signe de la de la faiblesse
de cette mondialisation qui est
peut-être excessive
en tout cas c'est le sait la preuve de
ses excès parce que quand on voit les
les images c'est amusant parce qu'on
voit le ce qu'elles réalisent réellement
la pollution marine par exemple et que
l'enjeu n'est pas du tout dans merad et
ceux qui ont acheté des véhicules diesel
parce qu'on les a encouragés à acheter
des véhicules diesel pour aller au
boulot on voit bien que les écolos de
ferait mieux de s'intéresser aux vrais
sujets ensuite ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il manque un bateau enfin un
cargo renversé c'est aussi tout
l'approvisionnement mondial en certains
produits qui est retardée alors là
c'était absolument pas le cas mais
posséder une politique fiction les
vaccins imaginait que les vaccins
étaient dans ce cas dans ce caveau
effectivement vous vous imaginez les
conséquences vous aussi
pour des raisons écologiques pas à mon
avis pour des raisons économiques parce
que c'est aussi comme ça qu'on créera de
l'emploi relocaliser un certain nombre
de de production me paraîtra une logique
assez saine
on voit là on précise que le ca y'est le
trafic a repris le bateau ayant été
dégagés nicolas parfois est ce que vous
vous êtes dit oh là là peut-être qu'on
est allé un peu loin dans cette
globalisation des échanges de
marchandises quand on voit la fragilité
du dispositif
un seul bateau était déjà en train de
risque et d'entraidé par exemple des
pénuries de papier hygiénique sais pas
pourquoi d'ailleurs celui-ci voyage
spécialement par le canal de suez fait
plutôt qu'un jugement de valeur moi je
trouve intéressant sur le dernier un peu
les lits faits et c'est vrai que la
mondialisation est fragile on le sait
toutes manières depuis 2008 où tout cas
ce cycle de mondialisation libérale
s'est achevée en 2008 elle est remise en
cause
avec le protectionnisme pour des réseaux
6 2 d'heureux de diminution de la
dépendance pour des baisers sociale et
aussi pour des raisons de l'écologie
mais ce qui me frappe moi c'est plutôt
sa résilience et la flexibilité
parce que vous voyez le y compris la
fermeture de suez pendant une semaine
en réalité la parade a été trouvée tout
de suite c'est à dire qu'il ya une
partie des oui il y en a qui stationnent
mais il ya toute une partie du trafic
qui fait le tour de l'afrique
donc évidemment ça coûte plus cher mais
ça ne s'arrête pas et l'art et la
résilience des chaînes de valeur et
quand même et quand même très importante
et je prendrai un exemple pratique vous
avez parlé des vaccins dans le savez
vous combien il ya de composants dans le
vaccin à pfizer
cette petite dose il ya 280 composants
différents et donc l'idée que tout va
être fabriqué effet dans le même pays
c'est quelque chose qui
et
et même dans des très grands pays comme
les etats unis c'est très compliqué donc
ce qui me ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est que si vous voulez y compris ce
qu'on les images qu'on a vu parce que on
nous a quand même annoncé la mort de la
mondialisation en 2008 et puis on
l'annoncé aussi pendant la pandémie
les images qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est
que ça n'est pas le cas mais ça veut pas
dire qu'il ne se passe rien c'est à dire
que je pense que pour des raisons
écologiques pour des raisons aussi de
diminution de la dépendance pour des
raisons stratégiques de découplage entre
les états unis et la chine
le système qui a prévalu à la au début
du 20e siècle il ne va pas égal à se
restructurer sur une base beaucoup plus
régionale mais je ne pense pas que la
mondialisation soit morte je pense
qu'elle est entrée dans une nouvelle
dans une nouvelle phase et c'est là où
les choses sont un peu plus me
semble-t-il un peu plus compliqué mais
voyez ces images y compris de bateaux
des emails ça montre bien que ce ce
système des chaînes de valeur globalisé
il n'est pas mort non le mahb surtout
constant on est d'accord moi j'ai
tendance à penser que la pandémie va
l'accélérer quoi qu'on en dise
d'accélérer notre dépendance vis-à-vis
de la chine qui a pris une longueur
d'avancé
accélérer la mondialisation par les
gaffes a qui vont devenir des acteurs de
plus en plus puissants donc
effectivement il y avait une forme
d'utopie du monde d'après on voit bien
que le comme le disait houellebecq le
monde d'après ça risque d'être le monde
d'avant en pierre ça ne veut pas dire
que ce système est extrêmement sans
bénéfique et c'est plutôt un système qui
nous a entraîné l'europe et
singulièrement la feue la france dans
une dans une forme de déclin donc je
suis pas du tout partisan pour
s'extraire de la de la mondialisation
mais réfléchir à notre indépendance pour
être un acteur puissant
je pense que c est là encore le rôle du
politique sera le rôle de politique dans
les prochaines années si on veut pas
être voilà coloniser économiquement par
les chinois puis à juste titre on
parlait de ce projet de loi climat qui
est complètement absurde puisque c'est
une salle de traite de rien de ce qui
est important puisque la priorité c'est
donc de lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique et donc il ya deux choses
fondamentales qui sont la taxe carbone
et l'énergie nucléaire et c'est tout ce
dont on ne discute pas dans ce texte il
ya un autre point qui a été soulevée par
alexandre de vécu et qui est en point
que je trouve important et qui est
sous-estimé c'est à dire que dans les
coop
on s'est beaucoup intéressé aux forêts
on a raison mais l'océan a été
systématiquement un des grands oubliés
or l'océan est encore plus important que
les forêts pour la régulation de la
température de la planète et c'est vrai
que je pense que le il ya eu très peu
d'efforts finalement et il faut
absolument accélérer parce que ces
monstres qu'on a qu'on voit aujourd'hui
qu'on voit en photo
c'est vrai que dans les ja leaders dans
les véhicules les plus polluants
il ya vraiment le transport maritime et
donc il ya un énorme effort qui peut
être fait et ont comme on part de loin
on pourrait vraiment améliorer les
choses de manière assez assez
spectaculaire et je trouve que sur par
exemple je pense que les industriels ou
comme vous savez il ya un sixième
continent du plastique au large du
pacifique c'est quand même incroyable ce
que le plastique c'est quand même c'est
du pétrole
voilà donc si on recycle on peut
récupérer du pétrole
alors effectivement et donc il ya de
vraies innovations à faire pour essayer
de nettoyer l'océan
d'abord d'arrêter de l'eau polluée de le
nettoyer et de recycler une partie des
déchets qu'on y a expédié de manière
complètement irresponsable vous parlez
de ces bateaux que vous qualifiez de
monstres il ya une image très frappant
qui a été utilisé
danger le confrère de l'express il ya
dizaine de jours par noël harari vous
avez le les céistes auteur du
célèbrissime sapiens et harari disait où
un seul porte conteneurs de très grande
taille
aujourd'hui transporte à lui seul trois
fois plus de marchandises que la
totalité de la flotte marchande anglaise
à la fin l'angleterre ayant étant à
l'époque la première puissance maritime
du monde et ajoute harari pour la flotte
anglaise avec ses soixante mille tonnes
ces 68 mille tonnes annuelles il y avait
seize mille matelots pour un porte
conteneurs avec 200 mille tonnes
il en reste 22 ans parce qu'il faut bien
voir que c'est plus simple c'est plus
encore quand on pilote quelque chose qui
fait 400 mètres de long deux cent mille
tonnes en fait c'est plus des véhicules
sont des îles flottantes et c'est ce
qu'on a vu d'ailleurs quand ça se met en
travers
c'est il faut bouger en fait il faut
bouger une île et donc bouger une île
c'est pas quelque chose de l'une des
premières leçons à tirer ptt éviter ce
type de baleines d'acier ou dit le
dealer en acier j'ai vu que oui dit le
lot mais enfin voilà et j'ai vu par
exemple les associations animalière
protestait parce qu'il y avait des
mamans des moutons des animaux est-ce
que là aussi dans la logique de la
régulation bien sûr qu'on pourra pas
tout produire de manière locale mais est
ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de consommer
des moutons qui viennent de l'autre bout
du monde
je n'en suis pas certain là où je vous
revu que ce ne soit pas des pangolins et
là où je vous rejoins c'est sans doute
pour retrouver la puissance et réguler
la mondialisation ça se passe au plan
régional avec sans doute une erreur
asiatique une aire et étasuniennes
et enfin d'amérique et une aire
européenne là où je diffère un peu avec
vous c'est que je pense que
effectivement il faut construire une
europe puissance mais je pense que ça
passera d'abord par la réalité des
nations et par des nations puissantes et
agile en tout cas la conclusion parce
qu'il ya un lien entre les deux thèmes
quand on prend la pandémie ou ce
commerce maritime
c'est que on s'aperçoit bien que pour
réguler tout ça et c'est la même chose
pour le climat
ce sont des problèmes planétaires et
donc il faut qu'on trouve des moyens
d'avoir des institutions ou des régles
dérégulation des règles adaptées à ce
système
elle ne parle pas des états la soul et
la faiblesse des institutions
internationales dont que ce soit l'om
est sous l'union européenne elles ont
fait la preuve de leur faiblesse et de
leur manque d'organes il est en tout cas
le monde à mort c'est le tout et où on
nationalise tout c'est certainement pas
un monde où on pourra régler ce type de
problème aux internautes sont aussi
partagées que vous quand on leur pose la
question est-ce que ce blocage du canal
de suez
c'est en quelque sorte une illustration
de l'échec de la mondialisation c'est 50
% oui 50%
non quelques commentaires maylis bonnin
sur youtube et le ce blocage n'a pas mis
en lumière l'échec de la mondialisation
mais son irresponsabilité son
incohérence écologique et sociétal
nicole 0,6 sur lefigaro.fr qui insiste
comme vous sur la pollution qui
et provoqué par ces porte conteneurs
géants jeux petits 74 sur lefigaro.fr il
faut retrouver la souveraineté
économique
et puis henri faure sur youtube les
responsables mondiaux n'avaient pas
prévu le coc vide
les responsables du canal de suez
n'avait pas prévu qu'une minuscule
artères comme celle là pouvaient se
boucher nous vivons dans un monde où les
responsables ou beat prévoir à -
alexandre de vidéos que se montre
devenue trop complexe pour qu'on puisse
prévoir quoi que ce soit et que là
l'important c'est de réussir à réagir
vite quand l'inconnu ce nom mais
aujourd'hui moi je pense ça ne sonnait
pas le signe de l'échec de la
mondialisation ça a été dit là où ils
ont réagi plutôt vite
malgré tout ils ont trouvé des solutions
des parades mais par contre je rejoins
la première aux internautes qui
expliquait que ça mis en lumière son
incohérence est une forme de folie donc
je crois qu'il faut revenir à une forme
de rationalité que la loi du profit à
tout prix
voilà je pense que c'est pas sans
vouloir faire de la morale c'est pas ça
et en plus je pense qu'à la fin ça se
paye aussi économiquement on le voit
avec cette crise sanitaire qui coûtent
des millions chaque jour
avec cette logique de confinement qui
était qui s'est installée voilà en tout
cas le canal et dégager les moutons vont
pouvoir passer au renom ainsi du gigot
pour pâques merci beaucoup à bien les
deux merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
et à demain
[Musique]